Salut, aujourd'hui je vous fais cette vidéo depuis les loges de Villars où je joue mon spectacle ce soir.
Et ça résonne beaucoup trop ! On change d'endroit !
[musique]
Voilà , ici ça devrait moins résonner, et en plus avec les lumières qui donnent sur le public, vous allez me voir.
Depuis ce début d'année, j'ai donc lancé deux nouveaux formats:
le Boost Brain quand j'ai un invité pour vous apprendre quelque chose mais lui aussi apprend à le faire en même temps, et comme ça, ça vous motive.
Et le Mental Experience, on en a lancé un.
Vous êtes pour l'instant plus de 30.000 à avoir répondu.
Il y a 4 personnes spécialisées dans les mathématiques qui sont en train d'analyser les données brutes,
et je préfère qu'on prenne le temps et qu'on ait une super analyse de tout ça.
Le format que je vous présente aujourd'hui s'appelle le "Hack Life".
Dans ce format là, je vous donnerai toujours des astuces avec votre mental, que ce soit du mentalisme, du non-verbal, des choses pour simplifier sa vie...
C'est le Hack Life !
On me pose souvent la question d'où est-ce que je trouve l'énergie de lancer toujours des projets, des défis, ce genre de choses.
Alors, je vais vous donner 5 points, ce sera toujours le cas dans le Hack Life pour avoir une vraie motivation et être capable de faire des choses au quotidien.
Personellement, je suis plutôt un procrastineur,
Je sais, ça ne se voit pas...
Mais, au fond de moi... Je sais que je suis un bon branleur.
La première chose que je peux vous recommander, c'est quelque chose qui marche et qui est efficace, c'est de se lever lors de son premier réveil.
Quand votre réveil sonne, asseyez vous tout de suite sur votre lit ou mieux au bord du lit
et vraiment, je ne déconne pas, même si vous pouvez chanter ou dire quelque chose... essayez d’enclencher la machine directement
Ca ne sert à rien de laisser : 5 réveils, 9 réveils, 10 réveils...
Vous attendrez toujours le réveil qui fera que vous êtes en bon état de repos pour vous lever.
Je vais vous le dire , il n'arrivera jamais ce réveil là.
Il n'y aura pas un matin où vous allez faire : AH ! P****n le réveil a sonné c'est bon je suis en pleine forme !
Cela n'arrive pas ! C'est toujours douloureux le réveil
Et vous allez voir que vous allez démarrer la journée plus facilement et en plus de ça , vous serez fier de vous.
La deuxième chose c'est de faire les choses petit à petit.
Ça ne sert à rien de vous donner une tonne de choses à faire pour la journée, c'est trop ambitieux, ça fait peur de s'y mettre, on ne sait pas par où commencer.
Donc organisez-vous !
Peut-être vous allez noter sur un papier, vous savez le principe des "todo list" dont je vous avais parlé.
Et vous vous dites: "Dans un premier temps aujourd'hui j'ai pour mission de ranger au moins ma chambre, ou mon bureau, ou ma cuisine, ou ce que vous voulez.
Faire les choses petit à petit, ça veut dire qu'à chaque fois que vous réussissez quelque chose, vous avez un sentiment de réussite en vous.
Et le cerveau qui lâche une récompense.
Et surtout vous voyez que vous avancez. Ça aussi c'est cool !
Il vaut mieux séquencer par étapes, que d'essayer de globaliser sur un terme générique.
Trouvez toutes les étapes et réalisez les une par une, petit à petit.
Et du coup on vient au troisième élément que j'ai un peu grillé qui est de faire des "todo list".
C'est très bon contre la procrastination, j'en avais parlé une fois l'année dernière
Une "todo list", c'est juste noter les choses que vous avez à faire.
Au global, que ce soit pour aujourd'hui, ou dans l'absolu toutes les choses que vous avez à faire
Notez les, déchargez-vous mentalement.
Une fois qu'on note les choses qu'on a à faire on se sent déjà plus libre, comme si on les avait faites.
Mais c'est juste parce que vous savez où vous en êtes.
Et je vous recommande aussi de les faire sur papier plutôt que sur une application parce que ça permet de rayer, de le voir. C'est plus intéressant quand c'est matériel que électronique
Après chacun fait ce qu'il veut !
La quatrième chose c'est concernant les pauses.
C'est important de faire des pauses, c'est pas grave de faire une pause, c'est pas grave de plus avoir envie.
Il vaux mieux s’arrêter quand on n'est plus productif, plutôt que d'essayer de continuer dans la souffrance et en fait de rien faire de plus à part avoir perdu deux heures pour pas grand chose.
C'est-à-dire que quand on n'a pas envie de bosser, par exemple, on va faire en deux heures ce qu'on aurait fait en une demi-heure quand on avait envie de le faire.
Il faut savoir identifier les moments aussi où on va s’arrêter. Ou s’arrêter ou changer d’activité, mais si vous vous arrêtez il faut que ce soit une vraie décision.
C'est à dire : "Non, là maintenant, j’arrête et je prends 20 minutes pour faire ça".
Pour lire, 20 minutes pour regarder la télé, 20 minutes pour jouer sur mon téléphone.
Mais c'est vous qui devez décider ça et ne pas vous laisser avoir et subir.
C'est ce qui fait que sinon on reste comme ça, durant des heures dans son canapé à dire: "Allez je m'y mets là. Bon allez, à la demie, je m'y mets...
Bon allez, dans une heure je m'y mets !"
Et en fait, on ne s'y remet jamais. Vous devez décider.
Être maître du temps qui passe, être maître de votre temps !
Donc, vous pouvez ne rien faire.
Vous pouvez faire des pauses, mais il faut que ce soit une décision de votre part.
Et la cinquième chose que j'ai déjà pu aborder, de près ou de loin, mais là, qui est importante pour cette vidéo c'est le pouvoir de la "Dead line" !
La "Dead line", c'est le pouvoir ultime !
Vous l'avez vu ? Je suis en train de le faire... Ha ! Non, je suis entrain de vous griller un truc !
Je suis en train de vous faire une vidéo spéciale en ce moment où je viens de vous dire quelque chose et j'allais le répéter. Mais non, mais je ne dis rien !
Vous saurez ça le 31 janvier, enfin bon !
Quoi c'est du teasing ? Pas du tout !
Ça fonctionne très bien puisqu'il y a des gens qui travaillent un peu dans l'urgence.
Je suis un petit peu comme ça.
C'est-à-dire que plus la "Dead Line" avance et plus on s'y met.
Si il n'y a pas de "Dead Line", il y a toujours une bonne excuse pour reporter.
C'est pour ça que peut-être, il y en a qui, entre vous, pensent depuis longtemps à faire des vidéos, ou à écrire un bouquin ou à faire ceci, à faire cela...
Et vous ne le mettez pas encore en place.
Parce que vous ne vous êtes pas imposé une "Dead Line".
Ce qui est formidable, c'est de se donner une "Dead Line", d'en parler publiquement aux personnes qui nous entourent.
Parce que ça met une espèce de pression, mais c'est une pression saine.
Alors après, si vous associez la "todo list" et la "dead line", Vous pouvez mettre des "dead line" dans la "dead line" et séquencer tout ça avec le principe de faire les choses également petit à petit.
En parlant de faire les choses petit à petit, je vous mets un lien dans la description vers un bouquin qui reprend tout ce principe là, de faire les choses petit à petit qui est très très intéressant.
Ce format là est un petit peu plus court volontairement, ça me permettra d'en sortir plus souvent
quand je suis entre deux vidéos un petit peu plus grosses, comme ça va être le cas là pour, le retour du Mental Experience.
Je pense que cette année, on va être rapidement à un rythme de trois vidéos par semaine.
Voire plus de temps en temps.
Je vous ai donné, moi les 5 points qui me paraissent essentiels pour se motiver comme ça au quotidien, mais vous aussi, vous avez surement des astuces.
N'hésitez pas à les mettre dans les commentaires et à réagir là-dessus entre vous.
Je trouve ça toujours intéressant que l'espace commentaire soit un espace d'échange pour vous, pour compléter en fait, les astuces que je donne.
N’hésitez pas à vous en servir, c'est chez vous, c'est à vous.
Concernant le spectacle, pour l'instant, c'est ouf !
Vous êtes partout, c'est complet, c'était complet à Saint-Galmier.
C'est là complet ce soir à Villars.
Ça va être complet demain et après demain à Vienne.
Il reste encore quelques places pour Brignoles et Aix-En-Provence la semaine prochaine.
Sinon, le mois prochain je serai également à Toulon pour quelques dates, également à Versailles à la Royale Factory et durant 15 jours à Grenoble, à la Basse cour.
Et pleins d'autres villes jusqu'au mois de juin.
Vous avez comme d'habitude tous les dates de tournée dans la description !
Je crois qu'il est l'heure d'aller prendre des médicaments... parce que ça doit se voir, mais vraiment...
j'ai une sale gueule, je suis malade !
Je joue avec de la fièvre sur scène, c'est chiant !
Bref, si la vidéo vous a plu, comme d'habitude, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner et de la liker
Et rendez-vous très bientôt, mais là, ca va être très très vite.
Très très, très très vite.
Ciao !
[musique]